it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes Mike that was such a great story
oh hey everybody welcome to movie fights
it's the all-new very exciting movie
fights and we are damn glad to bring you
a pretty exciting show today isn't that
right Mark Ellis movie hold that thought
you know what we've got three judges for
today's fight I'm one of the judges and
another one who's also going to be
holding it down on the fact checking
duties is you know me love mr. dan Merle
he said do you teeth how are you dad how
you feeling how how hard is
fact-checking like how much fever is
typing it depends it depends on if it's
a very factual round or not with these
two guys I'm guessing probably light on
facts today word on the street is this
may be our first fact free show
everything else we're going fact free
yeah there's um they're just backing up
Mike and Mark are gonna be backing up a
dump truck full of crap and dumping it
right into your internet she is very
factual very entertaining and we adore
the fantastic Danielle Radford Oh holdin
it down on the social medias tell us
what you're doing over there
um I'm going to be checking the YouTube
poll just to be sure it's the YouTube
poll for any of your ideas on who you
think should one I'm gonna be pointing
out any kind of funny comments I see
great ideas that you have and today what
I'm going to be doing is I am a
tiebreaker vote so if these two cannot
agree look at me
so a little change or rule you guys you
know what you guys have been giving us
suggestions in the YouTube comments
listen sometimes YouTube comments can be
a swamp accessable like I'm not gonna
laugh but you guys have given us some
awesome feedback and we one of the
things we've incorporated is
that Dan and I are going to give you our
vote and then we're going to go to the
social medias just to hear from you guys
and we're going to use your vote as the
tiebreaker if Dan and I are deadlocked
that's right well I card up there in the
corner
yeah vote on every round you can change
your vote if Mark Ellis changes your
mind you can go up then the I card you
can change your vote that's what they
want you to watch the show and vote
that's the whole thing mm-hmm
yeah I mean if you get swayed by Ellis
if you get cajoled by Carlsen or if just
like you know we cut to Dan and he gives
a dirty look and that changes your mind
there we go good dirty look Dan um oh
and Danielle if I can ask you one more
question if anybody throws up any sick
or dank memes let us know oh I'm giving
now them dank mans love it autumn thank
me uh we were talking to them but let's
welcome officially our fighters for the
day
Marc Ellis welcome back and you bow
thank you for coming over
good to be back from Schmo land and
touring where are you are you gonna be
performing stand-up comedy coming up you
know it's funny you asked that how I'm
gonna be the comedy story this weekend
in Los Angeles and I'm staying in town
next weekend for the Pasadena ice house
January 26 and 27 before I go to Omaha
in February so yeah should be fun
Mark Ellis swell guy and comic Road Dogg
yeah all the way to Pasadena oh man 13
miles and it takes three hours
great material mark alright it's
absolutely opening with that so the
crowd act surprised we don't worry
hey Pasadena what's the deal with that
row is bull this is an old friend of the
show I mean is it safe to say if movie
fights had like a Hall of Fame he'd
certainly I be voted on and probably in
it you know miss hashtag Botanica Mike
Carlson what's up hello thank you for
having me
I love the new movie fights it makes me
feel like I'm at a Senate confirmation
hearing I feel more like a part of the
political process in here I am thank you
for having me if I can plug can i plug
yes I got a podcast you guys know
podcast the ride it's about theme parks
it's me and a couple other funny guys
and if you like theme park take
a listen
oh man I everybody loves some theme park
BS of course you've been to that
Wizarding World of Harry Potter
I'll have I been there I've been to the
Orlando one at a loss and you guys it's
time for movie fights all right oh yeah
[Music]
yeah sick package jte
don't take that the wrong way um so just
as a refresher this is a one-on-one
competition we have three regular
questions and then we have four speed
round questions so it could be a
whitewash three-zip in the regular
questions but then we go to the speed
round it's anybody's ballgame okay
anybody's ballgame ah fellas are you
ready
um Dan Danielle are you ready let's do
this the dams already internet I hope
you're ready cuz we're getting into
round number one sit down and get ready
to comment yes what would be the worst
movie to use to introduce someone to the
concept of movies this was inspired by
their their American and English
language films going over to Saudi
Arabia for the first time first time in
35 years and though one of the first
movies they're showing is the emoji
movie great movie to introduce people
who haven't really seen movies if I
understand the ruling we're not allowed
to actually just take the emoji movie
right yeah a big something other than
the emoji movie is the only movie that's
off the table so again if you're gonna
show one movie to an audience that would
ideally kill the concept of cinema to
them altogether what movie would it be
and why I think we've explained that
question enough Mark Ellis what do you
got al I'm gonna say Darren
Aronofsky's very controversial divisive
mother mother with an exclamation point
not just for the reason that movie
titles usually don't have exclamation
points that can confuse a new movie goer
it's also because the movie is
incredibly dense and tough to figure out
there's no storyline there's no plot
there's nothing that we really go to the
movies to see other than a bunch of
weird images and it's very biblical the
Bible doesn't really play overseas as
well as it plays here the Bible doesn't
real
work in Saudi Arabia like it does in
certain parts of America so I don't
think that a movie that relies so
heavily on biblical imagery and
confusing themes and threads is gonna
work for an audience it is not seen a
movie in a long time when you go to the
movies and you're looking at it through
a child's eyes you want to see something
fun something light-hearted something
that has some need action a cool story a
hero to root for Mother has none of that
it just confused professional movie
critics what do you think is going to do
to people who've never seen a movie
before it's gonna do the worst possible
thing it's gonna kill their love of
cinema Marc Ellis coming out of a gate
with passion Mike Carlson what do you
got well look you know when you're
introducing the concept of movies to
people it's very delicate you know you
want to make people love cinema as much
as you do as much as marked as much as
hell does so you would not start with a
movie that parodies other movies so
successfully I'm of course talking about
disaster movie a movie I've brought up
on the show once maybe twice I don't
know someone can check that this is a
movie that sends up hilariously whole
host of movies look Kung Fu Panda Iron
Man Hulk Hellboy why are they in a movie
about disasters I don't know but they do
such a good job of parenting people are
going to be very lost if they haven't
seen those original movies and the thing
is they're gonna you know see hell boy
and he's gonna like fart or something
and it's gonna ruin Hellboy for them
when they go try to see Hellboy so it's
not only going to do a bad job it's not
only going to confuse them it's also
gonna ruin all these classic characters
and classic films for the new film goer
and we want these people to love cinema
like all of you guys and when I get
really low by the way I look very creepy
Wow
we have passion we had poignancy dan
police fact check whether Hellboy farts
are not in the disaster movie I think
you could use Martin I think no Golden
Army would have been better with more
farts gentlemen fight it out I mean look
a disaster movie it's a cute answer
because oh it's a spoof of other movies
but it's not going to it the disaster
movie could make people happen there's
so many characters that you see in that
poster I guarantee you a new audience
member two movies is gonna glom on to
one of them even if it's just one scene
where I
man makes a joke it will make more sense
than anything you see and mother mother
not only will make you hate movies
it'll make you hate humanity in general
it's everything that is bad about humans
and then you put that into a movie form
where people are gonna rebel against
that art form it's gonna have people
running back to bucks Mike that's the
last thing we want we can both agree we
do not want people reading anymore that
thing that we can both agree on but look
when I when the famous disaster movie
scene when Ironman shits in his Ironman
suit we don't want them they're gonna
see as far as I'm concerned it is a real
scene we do not want people to think
that's the real Ironman it's gonna ruin
the whole Marvel Universe for them okay
that's not we're on sure mother is a
weird series of images but that's fine
it's like looking at a weird screensaver
okay these people are just gonna go okay
maybe they'll be a bit confused by it
but it's gonna be a better choice than
tarnishing all of these classic
characters if it's a screen saver I say
hit refresh
I'll move the mouse because we never
want to see that again you see Iron Man
crapped his pants you see Hellboy fart
is you see Hulk show his way it's all
gonna make people intrigued as to what
the hell this character is it's gonna
make people want to see more movies
whether it's a Marvel movie or a DC
movie or another comedy comedies are
meant to unite people how you get people
in a room you get them laughing and it
makes you feel good it makes you feel
like a child again
it's a uniting force it's a community
experience and people are gonna want to
pursue more of those if you give them
something like disaster movie you give
them something like mother the movie
ends everybody feels weird you don't
want to talk to anybody you don't want
to go out for dinner afterwards you just
want to go home and sit in your house by
yourself and think what the hell did I
just do with the last two hours of my
life I might end it right here huh when
you learn to swim people say throw you
in the deep end that's how it works okay
you go to something that's challenging
first you don't just wade in okay you
don't put your water wings on you show
someone something challenging by a man
date like Darren Aronofsky
who is a genius he's made some great
films of course there is certainly merit
in it is it confusing yeah of course it
is confusing but it was also hard for me
to jump off of a high dive and swim okay
there was a lifeguard who had to pull me
out of the water but that's okay because
I
to be tough I learned to be a good
swimmer these people and then there's a
vortex that is a wormhole that leads you
to another dimension where movies should
not exist that is what mother is
disaster movie is too challenging in a
different way okay this is going to look
if you look at that I have the poster
right here Indiana Jones in the Crystal
Skull Cinderella okay this is going to
make all of these franchises just
terrible they're gonna be waiting for
the scene where Indiana Jones falls off
of a boulder and poops in his pants okay
and that is gonna be bad that is going
to ruin a classic character I am more
concerned with that than people being a
little confused because of some weird
shots in mother how life in Saudi Arabia
might not be as easy as it is here in
America I don't know if they have fancy
podiums and pencils that are mostly
sharpened okay I don't know what's in
Saudi Arabia but I know this oil there's
a lot of oil in Saudi Arabia alright and
watching something like disaster artist
yeah it may be a little slick but if you
watch mother you're never going to the
movies again mother is one of those
things that will turn you off to an
entire art form disaster movie is not a
good film by any stretch of the
imagination but it can make people
interested in the art form it can be
funny if you get one laugh out of
disaster movie it's gonna serve a much
better purpose than saying anything that
you could possibly get on the mother
what was the best anybody ever felt
walking out a mother I'm sure there's
some teenagers and enjoy disaster movie
for what it was nobody walked out a
mother even if you loved the movie
skipping and saying hey we should go
right back to the movies you went home
you sat in the dark and you soaked
disaster movie moves way too fast for a
new movie goer the jokes come fast and
furious you can't keep up with the
hilarity okay mother doesn't have that
problem as far as jokes are consumed we
want to escape ISM in our movies how
especially when we're kids we don't want
to think about the real world mother
that makes you think about there the
very existence of humanity I'm gonna get
into all that crap I want to escape I
want to have a nice light-hearted goof
and something that a character is doing
what's Batman doing what's that creepy
panda in the corner
the movie poster doing wise Michael Cera
ish character in there is that actual
Michael Cera I don't know I should go
see the movie again to find out the
disaster artists is pure hilarity and
escapism mother is anything but that it
you feel trapped in your own body
for the record disaster movie not
disaster artist did I say disaster
artist
yes that's my passion coming through
because I am an artist of oration okay
I'm gonna ask you to do a little role
play here okay so you each say this is
the worst movie this movie would not
would inspire people to avoid the cinema
forever I want you to transport yourself
into the mind and body of a first-time
movie goer who just saw your film and
give us that person's genuine reaction
and review so you're the person who just
saw disaster movie you're the person who
just saw mother exclamation point for
the first time first movie what is your
take on the movie and cinema we're going
to start with my Carlson hmm well I'm
gonna do this like as if I was recording
a Captain's Log into like a diary at
night great hi this is Mike's journal
October 17th 20 22
I just saw my first film it was a movie
called disaster movie and I've heard
about films for a while
and I've always thought I should try it
so I did and I'll be honest with you I
kind of recognize a lot of these
characters Iron Man Hellboy and it was
just it was weird how they all were
in their papers and it's like I
didn't even think that that was a big
part I guess that's a part of all these
things I didn't really when I was
reading about movies it didn't say
anything about how all the characters
just were vomiting and in their
pants but for whatever reason yeah I
don't know movies might not be for me
got it thank you thank you for that and
you do a journal like that every night
yes yes okay
Mark Ellis
please hey I'm mark I just saw a mother
and boy could I have used so much
in their pants halfway through
that movie I'm done with the movie that
I walk on then this is what I do I'm
leaving a theater and there's no words
that need to be said because they don't
worry about them and mother why would I
worry about them in real life anymore
I walk out of the theater and I just go
I'll do the other one and then I'll
never have to see a movie like that
again after you blind yourself are you
going to have sex with your biological
mother that's Oedipus you guys Oedipus
Rex um thank you Mark Ellis all right
let's go to final thoughts Mark Ellis
transition into your final thoughts
Darren Aronofsky's mother you may have
appreciated for its artistic integrity
you may have hated it because it did a
lot of weird things took a lot of
chances that's not what anybody who's
seen a movie for the first time wants to
see when you saw a movie for the first
time were you applauding the movie
Taking Chances or showing you something
referencing the Bible no you saw movin
you wanted to see fun and happiness you
wanted to see a poop joke occasionally
you wanted to see somebody singing and
dancing you wanted a light-hearted fun
escapist affair that is the antithesis
of what mother is which is why it should
never be the first movie that any
culture sees thank you sir Mike Carlson
final thoughts traumatic experiences
helped us grow as humans and I think
that is what mother is maybe you don't
like it maybe you don't like putting
being put in unpleasant position but
even after you stabbed your own eye you
wake up the next morning and you realize
you've learned something and I think
that that's a good thing I learned to
never go see movies again son meanwhile
does that a disaster movie is a movie
where people will watch Kung Fu Panda
fill up a diaper and then they'll be
ruined for the rest of the movie going
days time all right wow what an
impassioned barn burner that was let's
go to Dan Merle for the
the facts and for his decision on this
first round surprising number of facts
here how many people their pants
he'll get to it are looking up Captain
Underpants the first epic movie
ironically the other movie that was
where the first screened in Saudi Arabia
was the emoji movie and Captain
Underpants which kind of ended up being
a point in this fight really this came
to the crux of this came to I believe
Mike's defecation argument and from a
factual standpoint here's what I've
discovered superhero movie not disaster
movie has an extended fart scene but
that's a different movie
I looked up disaster movie Iron Man does
make appearance he's crushed by a cowl
though as is Hellboy also crushed by a
cow to be played by Tony Cox who you may
know as the little person who was Bob
Billy Bob Thornton's friend and Bad
Santa
yeah sucked into a ceiling fan and tried
out the window however no evidence of
any of these characters defecating their
pants just in my defense I was being
figurative I live in the world of facts
and so not metaphor and so because Mike
made actual pants such the crux
of his argument I have to stand by the
facts I give the point to Marc
all right that's one for Mark Ellis
these allegations of fecal matter will
not stand
apparently so you both points were both
making me make me laugh and points for
choosing just divisive movies that would
be difficult to watch but all of the
points I just said points for this
points for that they're non-existent
because we only have one point for this
round and I got to give it to only one
of you Mike you didn't bring up the fact
that Kim Kardashian is in this movie
it's it's her first mainstream acting
role and
also it maybe it's kind of neat that you
get Batman and Iron Man in the same
movie it's a it's a fun crossover mark
you know you uh you didn't really take
down his his movie in that strong away
for me but you had a lot of good points
as far as mother would be a very
difficult experience for a first-time
movie goer and man it's a very difficult
decision but I also have to go with Mark
because you actually the point that it's
so difficult to embrace that just tough
material oh and then you did up one good
point about Mike's and as much as comedy
is a universal language and you'd want
to start with a comedy perhaps feels
good to laugh and the people Saudi
Arabia I'm with you I'm happy now it's
my candidacy to be your next president
Wow we broke it here but um you know
what what I'm trying to say is Mark
Ellis gets the point in my book
Danielle Mark one but if if you were to
vote what was what was the internet
saying alright well just out of
curiosity for the folks that were voting
again I'm looking at all of the polling
on Twitter or not on Twitter I just
completely told you the Rockies I'm
doing looking at all the polling on
YouTube and some of you had some
questions about that if you go down to
the little gear thing hit the
annotations on and off you can see the
archived our I card if you're not able
to see it right now so as of right now
if this would have gotten its own vote
mmm it looks like everyone is agreeing
that disaster movie would have been the
worst movie to see if you've never seen
a movie before 54% to 45% a lot of
people agreed with the disaster artist
flub on asleep they're like it would
actually be a terrible movie to see if
you've never seen a movie before many
people I think being inspired by the
Saudi Arabia missive at all were like oh
Team America
would be a terrible movie well we didn't
say oh yeah yeah yeah and this one which
I really liked
at Road Raider 3 on Twitter said easy
one for me wreck reom for a dream I
don't think I need to explain that one
they won't do drugs or watch movies
anymore what a terrible thing to keep
people drug-free have you ever heard of
dare well oh how our audience is not
Juber come visit la weed is legal here
ok guys lots of fun good times right
there but shall we move on to the second
question of movie fights let's do it
pitch a fan edit you'd like to see from
a popular movie so there's been a lot of
news lately about the Zack Snyder
Justice League cut about the Star Wars
last Jedi cut taking all of the women
out of it for some reason we asked you
to to pitch a fan edit mm-hmm and we're
gonna start with Mike Carlson okay a lot
of people have a lot of complaints about
these new Disney Star Wars movies and
some people are saying you know it's too
much like the old ones some people are
saying women shouldn't be able to carry
a lightsaber around because they're too
heavy
okay and I don't agree with either of
those things but I do have a complaint
about them and it's that there are
barely any references to prequel
characters or prequel planets okay so I
propose a fan edit that adds in prequel
characters to the Disney Star Wars
movies okay now this is going to be this
is going to be a little hard and it's
like an advanced edit okay so I know
Topher Grace made that big super cut of
the prequels if he wants to be involved
in this I'm happy to oversee it
I mean this I a lot of people accuse me
of being glib and not taking things
seriously I want that picture so bad I
want that's one of the most exciting
things of when these movies were
announced that this was gonna happen and
they have let me down every time so what
I'm saying is you want we want new fun
scenes okay so like for instance in
force awakens
ray is a scavenger she goes and takes
things and she gets her quarter portions
or whatever and instead of unkar plutt
it's like a doll ray and it's Watteau
Watto is there and he's the guy working
at that booth why not why wouldn't it be
wat oh no he's on jakku because he's
Jewish stereotype Toydarian none of
these characters are stereotypes they
just have voices that might sound like
different ethnicities you know I'm just
defending Watteau here okay and then
I'll give you one more example okay so
Han Solo they're trying to figure out
and force awaken they're trying to
figure out where how they're gonna get
bb-8 and take him back to the resistance
and he takes them to maz kanata's okay
no way here's what I want I want him to
go hey Rafe and I want you to meet my
friend Dexter Dexter the 50 space diner
owner and they're in like the 50 space
diner from Attack of the Clones okay
that would be fun that would tie all the
movies together the prequels happened
okay they happen don't ignore them Wow
some prequel passion from Mike Carlson
Marc Ellis
what's the fan edit you'd love to see
nonsense Alderaan was destroyed how I
heard millions of people cry out in
terror holy crap that sounds like the
worst thing that can ever happen to Star
Wars my fan and it is simple how I mean
look there's there's good actors that
have been cast in bad movies and there's
bad actors that have been cast in good
movies but I've never seen a situation
like Keanu Reeves cast as Jonathan
Harker and Bram Stoker's Dracula it is
so easy to watch this movie and say this
is a masterpiece start to finish
except the guy from Bill
it's excellent adventure and his weird
accent are ruining every shot that he's
in in this movie you want to know what
Gary Oldman doesn't have an Oscar yet
because half the scenes he had in that
movie had to share with the dope from
speed okay
Keanu Reeves has become a better actor
he knows what he's capable of and when
he was probably at the premiere of Bram
Stoker's Dracula he's like I should not
have been in this movie this requires
you know good acting and this is not
what I can do you can cut him out of
Dracula and you can have a great movie
because the whole basis of Graham Stoker
is you can't look at that look how easy
that one for greats added a bunch of CGI
characters he just boom there he is
where's cannibal he's there now and then
two seconds later boom he's gone you
don't change the narrative at all the
Bram Stoker dragoo is based on Jonathan
Harker's journal you can have some actor
get a you get a Sir John Gielgud get
some Guinness sir Sir Richard
Attenborough just read I know they're
dead but you can okay you can have them
read from heart girls journal and just
have that be a voice over to the other
events to the things we actually care
about which is the guy Dracula Count
Dracula looking for his long-lost love
play by Winona Ryder that's the movie we
wanted and we got this other guy air
guitaring his way through very dramatic
important scenes and I think we can cut
it out all right Wow they both feel very
passionately about these fan edits fight
it out fellas
people are go people gonna be watching
Dracula and they're gonna go where's
Dracula's real estate agent he's gone
he's missing from the story
he's dragons really it's an important
thing and second of all Keanu Reeves he
seems nice okay she's nice in the movie
and I like that I like that he's maybe
not such a stodgy English character
actor or somebody who takes himself so
seriously and he he like studies his
part and learns his lines very well and
really worked on his accent I think it's
charming that he clearly just showed up
on the day and was like oh I could do an
English accent or whatever and it
sounded like that that's cute that adds
to the character okay yeah exactly I
don't from your description of putting
prequel characters back in Star Wars
okay we're basically both talking about
characters nobody
my movie just removes the 1 and your
movie just puts them back in we don't
want that when we said that Star Wars
should be more diverse with the new
movies we didn't mean that should
include Jamaican Asian and Jewish
stereotypical characters okay we want
real three-dimensional people Topher
Grace made his fan out of the you
reference you know what he did he edited
out Jar Jar the guy that you want to
shoehorn back in there were two
complaints about the new Star Wars
movies with the force awakens people
said it was just a rehash of the old
ones with the last Jedi they said oh
they're manipulating cannon in a way
that doesn't make sense your fan at it
would do both of those things in spades
it would be more of a rehash and it
would be some weird space time continuum
flip-flop that you would see in a bad
start Renault flip-flop these characters
existed why have we not seen anything
why have we not seen any evidence of
General Grievous okay where's his son
let's see General Grievous his son
General Grievous Junior you want open a
movie put him in rogue one where
they can die on the beach right everyone
okay they give you a little bail organa
but what was that role there was barely
anything in it okay and then we got
moose too far which by the way I was so
excited and then when it came time to
the big reveal when the tank was there
and I was like oh my god Hayden's gonna
be in the tank havens gonna be in the
tank Hayden was not in the tank and I I
very sad there is a reason why Hayden
wasn't in the tank and it's because we
gave him two movies and he wasn't good
in them so we said we should the point
yells in the Darth Vader that is beside
the point these movies aren't good okay
that's not what I'm arguing but they
happened and we have to acknowledge
that's a good thing about acknowledging
the pavlo that you can Cherie pick
things from Canon and say we want this
to continue one of these other things we
don't really want to do you really want
to talk about midi-chlorians do you want
yes I do none scientifically we got this
stuff that we wanted from the prequels
we had kylo Ren referencing a clone army
we had Yoda show up in the last Jedi we
got the people that we wanted we cut
everybody else Star Wars is like your
varsity basketball team not everybody
that tried out last year is gonna make
the cut this year maybe this is a
generational thing because I'm a
millennial and a certain section of
people young people the prequels are
their Star Wars movies
and we're turning our backs on those
people by totally ignoring and let's
also think about this we can
recontextualize characters they don't
have to be exactly the same way we can
make jar jar an eye patch gone he's gone
through a lot of in 30 years and
now he's a Marauder now he's a guy who
will like that up I can we say eff
yes you can say the letter F you said a
panda dragging his pants three times but
I wouldn't be I wouldn't be vulgar okay
the argument is not worked for me at all
because what a Millennials want they
want to see more representation they
want to see more diversity of
three-dimensional characters not
stereotypes they want to see women
actually doing things and kicking ass
not just standing there with a bunch of
makeup saying I don't condone a cost of
action that'll lead us to walk that
those movies made good actors bad a lot
like what happened to Keanu Reeves and
company because he ruined everybody
else's performance we do not want that
Star Wars is off on a new direction
let's leave the prequels in the past
with stopping a rehash let's go new
places not keep retreading old
characters to satisfy some weird
fanservice fantasy you have well we're
already using old characters Luke Han
and Leia are old characters we need to
use the other old characters that people
like maze maze Indu has a daughter named
grace Windu wow man that's that's
beautiful you're reporting a monster so
uh mark I want you to give us a live
actor who would do the voice-over
narration in Bram Stoker's Dracula
because you did pitch to dead people who
would your live actor be Jeremy Irons
because you're the Irish accent and it
would be him looking back on the past
and he would be saying this is something
that went down and it was crazy and I'm
gonna tell you all about it right now
when I was a young man give us a little
more of that summon a little Jeremy
Irons give us a little of the narration
from Bram Stoker's Francis Ford Coppola
re-edit of Dracula I remember the day
like it was yesterday I got the call
from my boss at B&B Realty and he said
Hey how's your morning going I said it's
good you say well I got a big job for
you you're gonna take a horse and you're
gonna go to this weird castle with this
guy with really crazy hair
likes to lay with chicks with fangs and
it's gonna be dark and the weather
doesn't look good
I think you're the right man for the job
give my best to Winona Ryder and I
accepted the offer wow I like that got a
little slot done hell yeah and then we
hopped in the carriage and we rode for
three days I read lend those horses top
speed was 17 miles an alley boy did my
ass hurt when I got to the castle all I
wanted was a hot bath in it it was great
being in the counts presence until he
started rubbing my shoulders and then he
bit my neck and I was like this guy's
crazy
but I think I can sell it thank you Mark
Ellis thank you Mark Ellis for a
dramatic reading little saucy er than
the original material I don't think Bram
Stoker's the word an ass yeah no he did
yeah Stoker big ass man um Mike
what would a scene between kylo Ren and
Jar Jar Binks look like sound like okay
so kylo obviously he would be welcoming
Jar Jar into his his parlor and he would
be Jar Jar would be reporting back to
him about a mission he had just gone on
for cut so he'd be like colorin wait no
no that is kylo ren's whoa hold on a
second I have got to recalibrate here
Jar Jar Binks to the mission go
successfully and then he would throw the
head of that medical Jud blue medical
droid that I can't think of the name of
you know the one the blue medical droid
from force awakens and then you've
you've killed the medical droid just
like I asked you to yes he would say and
then the scene would be over Wow very
dramatic let's get three final thought
heard from Winona yet final thoughts I
met another boy look Bram Stoker's
Dracula is a great
it could have been an all-time classic
it could have been up there with Francis
Ford Coppola is greatest works that
Godfather 1 and 2 but there was one
stick in the mud and that sticks name is
Keanu Reeves I love you Keanu I love
your entire body of work with one huge
exception it is a black eye on the movie
it is a stain on his resume we can wipe
it off from the face of the earth right
now if we so choose how let's make that
call thank you Mark Ellis Mike Carlson
put a button on your argument as I was
watching clips from Bram Stoker's
Dracula today I was watching piano and I
was saying this guy's cute you know I
like this I like what he's doing here
Jeremy Irons is somebody who's a great
actor but would bring frankly too much
gravitas and not that naive naivete we
need for this realistic looking back on
his crap it's not him in the present
chairman as far as the prequels these
are characters that just because some of
us jaded older folks don't like them
they are very beloved to a whole set of
people and we can take these characters
and we can make them so everyone likes
them we can bring them into the fold in
new and exciting ways in the last Jedi
there was that whole thing with the
weird animals and freeing the animals I
say get rid of it put podracers in there
Sebulba guess gah no and my favorite
podracer of all team topo galleys we
will finally get these characters and
they will be done the right way with
cool new special effects and a whole new
generation of older people will enjoy
them time wow what an epic battle you
two
those are fan edits you know what
frankly I wouldn't want to see either
but you said Keanu's cute and it's true
his accent is it's quaint and adorable
and really out of place I think mark
really nailed it when he said that it is
that it is like it is like a piece of
poo poo and an ice cream caca yeah
because they would say back then or yeah
and it just it ruins
something that's really great and you
had them until you broke off the grace
window and then that Jar Jar kylo seem
that took the day for me yeah yep you
persuaded me to see something that I
didn't want to see I'm going point Mike
Carlson let's go to Dan Merle a couple
of factual things Marky referenced Gary
almond having to share the screen with
the dope from speed actually the time
that Dracula came out at camera would
have been the dope from Point Break or
the dope from Bill and Ted speed had yet
to come out at that time I can find no
canonical or non canonical reference to
General Grievous having a son or the
existence of grace Windu here's where I
stand I think that Mike is very clever
thank you and and a funny guy thank you
and I think that he took a lot of
Liberty but that's why I'm going the
other way because this is a question
about a fan cut not a drastic rewriting
of a movie and I feel like Mike's
changes were a drastic rewrite of the
source material I think that exceeds the
mandate from the question of the fan cut
so from a factual basis I have to go
with mark who I think proposed an actual
fan cut versus a complete reimagining of
the source material which is what Mike
if it was an alternate universe question
that I think Mike would have had it but
I have to stick to the question and the
facts and that's what I'm going with
mark Dan Merle extremely well reasoned
thank you sir we are deadlocked at one
and Daniel Radford you got to break that
tie and talk to us okay well this isn't
me this is all y'all voting on YouTube
yeah this is the YouTube vote um so
don't at me
and as of right now the YouTube votes
they that is really close they're super
close but they they're really going with
mark with Dracula they think that Merck
had the better argument I will say some
of the things I saw on Twitter all of
you want to turn the Hobbit trilogy into
the hala twin RG
like yeah they all want to make it into
one movie yes so the first person to do
that is gonna make some money and then
at bingeing netflix on twitter said fan
edit of the last Jedi where they get rid
of all
of the humans it's a five-minute comedic
short about Chui trying to eat porks a
la Tom and Jerry or I guess I mean I
don't know if he was I maybe like the
Road Runner and the wily coyote coyote
yeah that's called minions and that's
already out so Mark Ellis is the point -
Oh Mark Ellis for the record of both
good movies but I would love to see a
fan edit mashup of Dunkirk and darkest
hour no worries huh you still won the
point all right it's - oh and we are
going into round three and this is a
blind fight yeah I already poked my eye
out you still have one good eye though
okay so you have to choose one of these
names Chris Hemsworth or Michael Pena
I'll go a Michael Payne yeah he said
Hemsworth he gets Hemsworth you got
Michael said Payne's worth I did you
know I'll take both of them judges we're
gonna give it to him I'm gonna give him
Hemsworth you have Michael Pena so guys
12 strong starring both Chris Hemsworth
and Michael Pena hits theaters tomorrow
our very own Daniel Radford got to talk
to these stars and ask them a movie
fights question hmm
check out the clip 19 minutes act our
country the 12 of you will be the first
ones to fight back if you were going
into battle which three movie characters
would you want to bring with you it'd be
Rambo Jason Bourne and Joe Pesci Joe
Pesci ask Joe Pesci which one's yours
hmm if there was some water in the
bottle outside the shark from Jaws t-rex
from Jurassic Chris Pratt Chris Pratt
Chris Pratt from pretty much anything
can do Chris Pratt as a t-rex is your
there you have it what three movie
characters would you take into battle
with you you
have you've heard the Army's you have
them assembled Danielle quick question
was Hemsworth as dreamy in real life as
he is he's so dreamy I forgot that I
wore the same dress he's the good
Hemsworth too
yes lucky Chris Hemsworth talking to
dressed I refer to Liam Hemsworth as the
lesser Hemsworth Sam don't get me
started the rest of the family all right
so you each have your armies Mark Ellis
given give us an opening salvo for your
battalion I am very confident going into
battle with the crew that Michael Pena
was all too kind to assembled me with
because he had Rambo who's never been
hit by a bolt as far as I know Jason
Bourne who can get hit by bullets but he
survives he keeps on plugging with a
solid singular determination and then
Joe Pesci is himself Joe Pesci can talk
himself into any situation out of any
situation so Joe Pesci will help you
escalate the war then he'll also help
you find a compromise that's ingenious
of Joe Pesci and oh by the way Joe Pesci
is not a bad distraction as you know
from the home alone movies he will take
a licking and keep on ticking Joe Pesci
Rambo Jason Bourne
let's fight yeah this is Joe Pesci
thing's gonna be dicey cuz he just said
Joe Pesci so is there from Goodfellas is
it from home alive entire cat all right
there you go there you go there's an
elderly Italian man on your team Mike
Carlson first of all I want to thank mr.
Hemsworth for his chip picks I assume I
didn't hear the audio of the clip I
assume he knew I would be arguing for
him he just had a sort of a sixth sense
about it I want to say that look my team
is amazing Van Dam from bloodsport this
is a guy who's just a maniac you
can say there's only one way to describe
you maniac the shark from Jaws as we all
know very scary and a big just large
okay when you when you're dealing with
things it's hard to beat something
that's so large okay
stand third I'm not quite sure what he
means by Chris Pratt as a t-rex but I'm
gonna choose to assume that he means
Chris Pratt has mutated into a t-rex
somehow so there is a t-rex Chris Pratt
hybrid so we got first of all the t-rex
is gonna be funny we know that he's
gonna be quipping he's gonna be a big
movie star but he's also a giant t-rex
who is going to be a murder machine
these guys are gonna take out the other
guys especially because Joe Pesci is
just himself a cheesy 70 year old
Italian actor he's gonna be
non-committal as what I'm saying he
doesn't know what project he wants to do
it's a people tried to get him out to do
movies and he only works with Robert De
Niro so if De Niro is not on this list I
don't say Marty or Robert De Niro are on
this list I don't think Joe's coming out
of the house old man strength Joe
Pesci's got it he shows up cannot be
killed by conventional weapons because
he's too damn old Joe Pesci is the guy
that will arm wrestle he nearly why am i
losing to a four foot one lawn ornament
that won't stop talking to me it's
because it's the magic of Joe Pesci and
then I have to a list fighters on mice
well I have Rambo and I Jason Bourne he
has the sharks sharks don't play away
games all that well okay look no Bram
bow and Jason Bourne there's no movie
where they fight a t-rex okay neither of
them have a t-rex movie let alone a
funny t-rex movie okay this t-rex not
only is going to eat them but he's also
gonna be able to say quips and asides
that are gonna distract them and they're
funnier he's the funniest guy on this
list t-rex Chris Pratt funnier than
anybody on that other list you're making
a lot of assumptions about Chris Pratt's
ability once he turns into a dinosaur
think most of us turning into a dinosaur
would be confused by why our arms are
suddenly so small and if he wants to do
stand-up that's fine he can grab the
microphone like this but he's not gonna
be very good in battle when you have
Rambo with that huge gun just
goo-goo-goo
against the t-rex and then dan dan from
bloodsport how we're talking about a guy
who only operates in slow motion he
cannot fight in real time every clip
from bloodsport is just him reacting
slowly to something this was a guy who
got confounded by sand sand ruined Van
Dam in bloodsport and by the way I don't
think the shark from Jaws is gonna fare
much better on sand because you know the
whole Gil breathing thing
in look in this version of Chris Pratt
as a t-rex he's been a t-rex for a long
time okay so he's been a t-rex for like
ten years so he's learned to talk and
he's learned to use his limbs alright
and yeah as far as Van Damme being at
slow-motion bloodsport that's a good
thing it means he can get out of the way
easier when all the bullets are flying
we'll see slowly as he goes like this
and this and dodges the bullets and oh
yeah by the way it's raining a lot
during this fight okay so jaws will be
there he can go there it's gonna be a
flood and jaws will be fighting that way
and Joe Pesci when he sees a flood I'm
staying in the house how let me talk to
you about modern warfare okay lay it on
me Joe Pesci is a good soldier he's
gonna run in there he's gonna do his job
is gonna be an old man we can strap a
bomb to him he's gonna take out some
measure of the enemy but when you talk
about modern war and how its fought no
two characters understand that better
than Rambo who's been through a number
of Wars himself through present-day
as has Jason Bourne he's been all over
the globe Van Dam from bloodsport as far
as we know he's never even been out of
the ring or the hospital to visit his
brother okay that shark from Jaws does
not know what a war is because it's an
animal that swims in the ocean and the
t-rex has no idea how to fight a war how
to work with other people Jason Bourne
can work on his own
Rambo can work on his own or they can be
a team they proven both of those things
in their film lineage you have a team of
three humans I have a team of two
animals and one man who's an animal with
his anger and his viciousness okay you
got there yeah okay you guys are very
well trained everyone except profession
who is very well trained as an actor but
not is so well trained with guns and
weapons and fists my guys have nature
behind them
nature mother nature is the biggest
killer as we all know my hell knows
evolution behind them we're gonna go in
there we're gonna kick ass they're gonna
win the war and then Joe Pesci's gonna
turn on all the faucets and leave them
on because that's what a wet bandit does
to leave their calling card okay break
down a little bit more about what this
collision would be like I want to hear
okay if your army of three collides with
your army of three what's gonna be left
in the wake what is the what is the
damage gonna be done I want you to paint
a vivid bloody picture for me start with
Mike Carlson okay the battle now that I
think about it the battle takes place at
Sea World it's it's a lot it's right
it's a SeaWorld in San Diego it's right
by the ocean so there's gonna be a ton
of water around all right and very
smartly Van Dam from bloodsport has
tricked Rambo Jason Bourne and Joe Pesci
there by saying that there's like a you
know a kid it's like you know somebody
kidnapped the kid and they're like okay
we better go get this and then Joe Pesci
also he's in a house in Jersey and he's
like I don't know about a kid I don't
want to I don't we what are we doing
here so he's not even there
we don't know maybe he'll show up later
it's raining at this point van Dam from
bloodsport he's in slow motion everyone
else doesn't even know how to react
because there's a slow-motion
jean-claude Van Damme and they're very
confused by it while that's happening
jaws jumps out of the tank and eats that
all of them and then Chris Pratt as the
dinosaur goes that's lunch you ended it
with a nice quip there thank you Mike
Mark Ellis described this collision yeah
I'm looking at this like we're invading
a fortress that is currently held by a
t-rex a shark in a tank of water and
who's your other guy Van Dam from
bloodsport so here's how the battle goes
now first of all Mike's premise is built
on a faulty layer of saying that Rambo
or Jason Bourne are gonna care about a
child nobody's showing up if a kid gets
kidnapped if you've seen any of these
people's movies you know then I really
care about humanity they care about
winning
Wars they live for the fight so here's
how it goes down there in a fortress Joe
Pesci's the first one to show up he
knocks on the door and he starts talking
to him he's cracking him up he's telling
stories about being on the set with De
Niro and with Scorsese and the home
alone movies and everybody's laughing
having a good time meanwhile Jason
Bourne has been doing recon figuring out
where Rambo could get the perfect
position for his drying a good gun and
then Rambo sets it up while they're
being distracted by Pesci he takes
everybody out the t-rex got hungry went
off to go some pasture eat horses okay
then you have the shark there's just
swimming around
nobody's fed the shark in a long time
because again Pesci's been entertaining
everybody so maybe they feed Pesci to
shark that cancels that out but then you
still have to worry about Van Dam from
bloodsport who again is how he has no
guns he barely has clothes on we take
him out with one bullet all we need is
one bullet to win this war how and we
have three people who are really good at
shooting stuff there you have it Wow
what a collision that would that only
exists on this virtual battlefield that
you gentlemen so beautifully created Dan
Merle give us your thoughts you know how
people can say that they don't like the
two fighters and they can say that they
don't like the standing but I don't
think they can say this episode was too
serious there's a fax to go on here yeah
let's be honest works can't live out of
water but but you both you both
presented plausible battle scenarios so
I I have to I have to go with was do I
have to go with my gut and and and I
think again this is all about tactics
and I think that that mark surrendered a
tactical advantage that he may not even
realize he did which is at one point he
said that Joe Pesci's a wet bandit and
that he would turn on the faucets and I
think that place right into Mike's hands
since he has the shark from Jaws because
if that house floods then that's the
Avenue and one of Mike's big things was
that our marks methinks is that the
shark is neutralized so based on that I
have to give the point to Mike I don't
think you understand how sharks breathe
um needs to be a lot of water there well
it's a wet bandit mark
that's a lot shape all I can shed in
shape of water they fill up a whole room
and an animal is fine in it yeah so an
animal has sex okay it was a small
tactical mistake okay that's that's 104
Mike Carlson man you guys you painted
some vivid battle pictures a lot of a
lot of bullets flying a lot of blood
everywhere but at the end of the day
Mike I think you and your scenario you
are a little too reliant on like jaws
behaving like think about like a trained
dog or something like like you said jaws
will just jump out of his uh out of the
swimming pool and eat whoever I mean
jaws does what jaws wants done Josh
doesn't do what you want him to do
because I haven't given it to Marc Ellis
tied up one one probably just as tasty
as any of those other guys Yeah right
you might eat Van Dam yeah he might even
eat Van Dam you can't you can't wrangle
a shark like that Mike Carlson got
together man Danielle what are they
saying when what is the deciding vote
oh the disappointment in your and your
voice I'm so looking at the vote once
again we're doing it off of the YouTube
it looks like the vote is 42% for mark
and mike has won this with 57% Wow wait
no one takes it day you know it's that
classic conflict of man versus man man
versus himself man versus Chris Pratt
t-rex and one comment that I really
liked online was at Troy Watson said
they would pick their team would be Ryan
Gosling from Blade Runner 20 49 Ryan
Gosling from Drive Ryan Gosling from the
notebook it's an all Gosling team sure I
think Joe Pesci would win that fight by
himself yeah I like it how in yours you
were just like yeah we'll sacrifice Joe
Pesci like it
the guy's gonna talk you into a win then
he's gonna talk himself back into a loss
like Joe Pesci is good for a certain
amount and that amount is distraction
and shark bait good point
gentlemen it's 2-1 Mark Ellis in the
lead it's time for the speed round where
it's anyone's game same speed round
rules apply they get 20 seconds 20
seconds and then rebuttals 10 seconds 10
seconds first answer out that person
will go first
you ready fellas I'm standing I mean ya
can't take it this is oh listen all
y'all it's a sabotage round referencing
the Beastie Boys classic alright do we
get slimed what is that a real thing yes
this is a sabotage round ok so each
player will hear the question and you
will get to pick your opponents answer
whatever you say will be your opponent's
answer that's how that works ok
best movie starring Eddie Murphy Norbit
thank you
Pluto Nash okay Mike
we'll be arguing for Norbit mark will be
arguing for Pluto Nash okay and first up
we have mark for Pluto Nash happy - I
know Nash didn't hit the mark at the box
office but it hit the mark in the funny
bone because Pluto Nash took Eddie
Murphy's career in a new bold direction
was it his best movie no but it was an
attempted something different at Eddie
Murphy had never tried before he was
trying to make a sci-fi fantasy comedy
and there worked some good laughs and
there's some some hints at the future
when he takes out the money it's $100
bills and Hillary Lacey gentlemen Norbit
is Eddie Murphy at what he does best but
badly so therefore it is a better movie
than Pluto Nash he is doing multiple
characters he is doing crazy stuff he's
flying downslide is he filling up
diapers like I was talking about earlier
probably yes probably folks Pluto Nash
is just sort of a lazy attempt at a
sci-fi Norbit is an effortful thing
where you get to watch Eddie Murphy show
his range on screen by playing a ton of
character Norbit is a desperate attempt
for him to recapture the fame he had
from the Nutty Professor playing
multiple characters and it ruined his
chance of winning an Oscar use the
front-runner from Dreamgirls then Norbit
came out right before the Oscars and it
said sunken I don't think that's true
second of all Pluto Nash that is just a
lazy cash grab on his part Norbit is an
effortful thing to watch a guy who tries
so hard it's like his Love Guru he is
putting his full ass into the movie and
it's much more time Wow Dan Merle oh boy
it was a bit of a close contest but
Mike's saying that Norbit was like Eddie
Murphy's love guru doesn't really endear
me to that point of view so I'm gonna
have to go with Mark on this one Daniel
Radford give us your thoughts oh geez um
yeah the showgirls thing really kind of
green dream real nice showgirls I was
but the Dreamgirls thing kind of nailed
it for me but I just ya know I'm gonna
I'm gonna go with Mark on this one I
like I like the arguments
Mark Ellis takes
I'd miss Eddie Murphy so bad though you
know he's still alive you have it did
you hear the movies we just talked yeah
surprise no one said a thousand words a
thousand words meet Dave Oh meet Dave
damn should we go back and forth with
those two right now no it's okay
next question speed round what franchise
should crossover with Pacific Rim
transformers Power Rangers we have
transformers we have Power Rangers Mark
Ellis you spoke first Pacific Rim is a
big robots fighting big monsters and
what better inclusion that having
transformers in there plus it would be a
boon to Pacific's rims box office we're
trying to help Pacific Rim here maintain
as a franchise transformers makes a
boatload of cash domestically and
especially overseas it's a global market
Power Rangers tanked at the box office
everywhere it opens so bad they're not
making a sequel anymore we've had a
bunch of Transformers movies
people love the Power Rangers and this
would be the infusion of coolness that
it needs now we have two different teams
of humans that get into giant robots and
they're competing for the government's
grant to fight giant monsters now we got
cool teens and we got older slightly
older teens fighting it out in giant
monsters this would be cool it would
present good human drama and we get to
see cool the megasaur the dragons are
there it's a very interesting conflict
in the Transformers franchise right now
because the robots aren't always
trusting the humans what happens to the
humans have technology to fight them at
their own game it could open up a whole
new dramatic doorway the giant robots in
the in Pacific Room cannot talk to the
transformers robots so that wouldn't be
fun at all so we're gonna have to have
the humans talk to each other because
the giant robots are not talking all
right this would be much what a
throwdown and let me tell everybody this
is a must-win for Mike Carlson mm-hmm
let's go to Dan Murrow pressure well
he's got my vote not only does he have
my vote he has my money if this movie
gets made this I want to see that
crossover I vote for Mike thank you okay
that's one for Mike Danielle yeah I
absolutely have to agree the literally
the only
you could have said that would have made
me want to see it more as if you were
like and the grant is to fight for the
rec center literally all that pitch
needed I'm in Mike Carlson takes it it
is three two we got ourselves a ballgame
that's a sports reference I still need
to win this next point
okay yes this is also this is another
must win for Carlson another must win
for Carlson is if Ellis takes it carlson
goes home a loser
all right gentlemen what mode of
transportation should Liam Neeson save
people on in his next action moving
monorail space shuttle okay we have
monorail and space shuttle Carlson going
first alright it has to be a Disney
World because there's a monorail at
Disney World so he has to save a bunch
of families that are on the monorail
that have been abducted by like some
evil Universal Studios people that I've
infiltrated Disney World this is gonna
be crazy we're gonna shoot it like that
escape from tomorrow that little bit
that gorilla film that was really bad
this is gonna be really good though and
Liam Neeson would be crawling on top of
the monorail while Disney songs play in
the back
the commuter was a horrific Liam Neeson
movie because it was taking what was
good about taking and ruining it by
confining him just to a train your movie
does the exact same thing if bleem
Neeson's on a space shuttle this is
great for a multitude of purposes he can
save the space shuttle he can save the
astronauts and he can be the one that
Bruce Willis's himself at the end of
Armageddon and he can fly in there that
way we never have to deal with another
taken movie ever again look we're gonna
take this takes place around Bay Lake
where there's a lot of different boats
and stuff so there's gonna be a
beautiful scenery okay it's not just
gonna be the same thing same thing we're
gonna go past the Grand Floridian the
contemporary the Polynesian Hotel all of
the hotels
Lee Mason has done the saving family
thing before now he needs to be a
scientist in command and he's the only
one that knows how to fly this space
shuttle this is the next logical step in
his career and maybe the last great
action movie that Liam Neeson does you
know what time Mark Ellis you made one
big mistake there you used logic okay
this man described a scene of Liam
Neeson crawling on top of a monorail
with Disney songs playing in the
background I give a point to Mike
Carlson let's go around to Danielle
Radford um you know that sounds great
but I have to agree with mercs argument
that we've already seen him kind of
saved a family plus yo I'm a simple girl
you tell me some is in space i'ma go for
the in space so I'm going with marquel
it's Sam it's one-one damn boy this is
very difficult because we have a
ridiculous idea and what sounds like a
very standard action movie I know which
one I should pick however I'm a little
more interested in Liam Neeson's tour of
the Walt Disney World Resort
that's the kind of movie that I want to
see I got a go I want to see that movie
we can call it Fast Pass yes okay let's
write that when we get out of here today
okay three three this is crazy
this one is for all the marbles and a
reminder whoever doesn't get this will
go home a loser you're not getting your
hand stamped this time that's what he
gets very good all right our final
question of the speed round more
surprising hit Jumanji or the greatest
showman the greatest showman Jumanji
okay Mark Ellis spoke first Mark Ellis
talks first audiences loved franchises
Jumanji is a built-in franchise it's a
beloved game that you could update
naturally with a video game you have
huge stars like The Rock in there the
greatest showman has Hugh Jackman and a
bunch of songs and dances it's about a
horrific person PT Barnum how is that a
hit with all the despicable things that
he did with humans and with animals you
put a bunch of show tunes and people see
it that is shocking
Jumanji is logically no one had that big
of expectations for that movie Jumanji
people are 20 years later you're gonna
do a reboot of a movie with the rock
it's gonna fail like why would we want
to see this people love this movie it's
not a movie that lends itself to being a
franchise it's shocking that it's such a
big hit great
Schulman is huge Ackman singing and
dancing of course people like that
people love that whatever the subject
matter is who cares but this you're
taking a beloved Rob Williams movie and
you're just like giving it is just love
franchises and I also love nostalgia
people growing up with the first two
Monty wanted to go back and feel like a
kid again the greatest showman just
makes you feel weird Rudi for somebody
that we in real life was a horrific bad
human being making something new is a
lot easier to have people accept it than
taking something beloved and to it
turning it into a different thing which
is what this movie does so it is
surprising I mean everyone thought this
thing was going to tank greatest showman
again singing dancing talented Wow Dan
Morrell this is like 5050 I they both
did a great job arguing their case I
honestly I don't I don't know which one
to pick it's like flipping a coin I
guess it would have to
I felt like Marc's argument was a little
OneNote with the whole PT Barnum is
despicable yeah I think we have to go
with Mike but it's very close it's very
close they both did a great job I hear
you brother that's one for Mike Danielle
oh yeah no I agree this was also really
hard but just based on the argument I
have to agree with Dan I I do I as much
as I agree that it's kind of hard to go
back and look at that I don't know if
that's necessarily what audiences are
looking at and so much is there like
Wolverine dancing so yeah I'm gonna go
with Mike Mike Carlson he is today's
winner
Mark Ellis you are going home elusive
yes sir
but but we love you and you're you're a
winner to us all day every day you know
waiting every day is hard how and it's
nice to take a break it's nice to take a
vacation I'm such a success story in
real life too just it's it's interesting
to feel like oh this is what it loser
feels like huh okay um all right please
plug some stuff again and tell us where
we can find you yeah pick myself up dust
myself off and go to Pasadena next
weekend at the ice out here things of
Mark Ellis live.com also hosts movie
talk every day on Collider subscribe to
schmoes know hell yeah Mike Carlson
congratulations thank you for a hobbit
taste of victory how does it taste those
like a diet dr. pepper
YUM please sponsor us diet dr. pepper
okay tell us where we can find you know
like fat Carlson at Twitter uh podcast
podcast the ride at Twitter and all the
things and go to Apple podcasts podcast
though ride yeah hear about uh like what
tacos at Disneyland we like you should
talk about that Liam Neeson movie anima
yeah we might yeah we'll get everyone
here and we'll all right and let me ask
you talk about your podcast sure healthy
um do you use such terrible language
like you use today on your podcast there
is an explicit warning on the podcast so
on occasion we get a little salty you
got a filthy mouth but I love you thank
you Dad Merle this was I'm just looking
at everyone so many people uh Danielle's
got her little things rigged it somehow
three judges you still think it's Riggs
how would that even work I don't know
anyway I want to worry about worrying
about if my lips are ashy than worrying
about it
he wasn't rigged everybody okay
I actually am a loser all right the
winning thing was the joke part ya know
how this is such a good time and to
underscore it you said when we started
was I know this is a change from the
movie from what movie fights used to be
and we are listening to what you say we
train you know folding and some changes
the show is evolving and as we do that
we just we hope that people will you
know give us a shot give this a shot see
what you think
we're excited about this we think it
opens up a lot of fun to avenues and we
hope that you'll you know give us some
time we're still working on it we're
still we're still tweaking we're gonna
tweak today we're gonna go do a tweak
meeting right after today was pretty
perfect
yeah thanks Dan Merle well put sir
Daniel Radford talked to us yeah yeah no
this was great I had a great time I
can't wait I everyone wants a rematch
from what I'm reading in the comments so
hopefully I mean I know we'll have both
of y'all back it's gonna happen Park you
lied about them this is gonna be a
Clippers rocket situation I'm upset um
yeah so this was great and yeah we're
gonna keep working I keep saying we I
show up with my laptop they're gonna
keep doing really hard work and I'm
gonna show up and thanks Danielle and I
also before we go I want to thank
everyone with the film 12 strong and I
want to thank Michael Pena and Chris
Hemsworth for being part of our dog and
pony show today easy 12 strong opens
tomorrow in theaters everywhere
I want to thank JT e in the booth I want
to thank Billy biz for a handle in the
biz and holdin it down and everybody
here and you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at Hal Rudnick and we'll see
you next time bye bye
you